say her name rihanna
say her name
a moment of celebration for the family
and friends of brianna taylor four
current and former louisville police
officers have been arrested on federal
charges in connection with taylor's
killing in march 2020. y'all learning
what we've been seeing was the truth
that they shouldn't have been there and
that brianna didn't deserve that taylor
was killed when louisville police
stormed her apartment looking for a drug
dealer
her boyfriend said police didn't
announce themselves and so he fired his
gun at what he thought were intruders
police shot back 22 times hitting taylor
in the chest
federal prosecutors say police knew they
didn't have the evidence to justify
raiding taylor's home but they did so
anyway
earlier today i spoke with the family of
brianna taylor
this morning they were informed that the
justice department has charged four
current
and former louisville metro police
department officers with federal crimes
related to ms taylor's death
those alleged crimes include civil
rights offenses
unlawful conspiracies
unconstitutional use of force and
obstruction offenses
the officers are also accused of
plotting to cover up their behavior
if convicted they could get up to 20
years in prison for obstruction and five
years for conspiracy and lying
along with the killing of george floyd
in may 2020 taylor's death led to
protests across the united states
against both racism and police brutality
the lawyer for taylor's family called
thursday's arrest a product of speaking
out because if we don't fight for our
children like brianna taylor who will
fight for them
the city of louisville paid briana
taylor's family 12 million dollars to
settle a wrongful death lawsuit
on thursday tamika palmer said the
arrests are just one more step in
holding the police accountable
today is overdue
but it still hurts
a recognition that all the legal success
in the world won't bring her daughter
back
rosalyn jordan al jazeera